어 건물주 바뀌셨다 바꾸실 계획이
있다 그래서 저희가 제안서를 써
가지고 어 저희 이런 매장을 이런
컨셉을 할 건데 저희한테 통임대 주실
생각이 있으시냐 이렇게 제안을 해
[음악]
가지고 안녕하세요 빌케 트 김지
있니다 오늘은 빌케 트 최초로 외부
게스트 분을 모셨는데요 먼저 소개해
드리기에 앞서 힌트를 몇 가지 드려
볼게요 요즘 mg 세대들의 플 팝업의
성지 하면 어디가 가장 먼저
떠오르시나요 바로 수동이죠 성수동
토박이 시고요 두 번째로 드릴 힌트는
박세리 님도 정하신다 성수동 디저트
카페 구키 씨 다들 아시죠 오늘은
성수동에서 여러 fmb 매장을
운영하고 계시는 성수동 영웅보스 구키
대표님 아니시고 김종영 대표님과
함께합니다 안녕하세요 대표님네
안녕하세요 대표님 소개한 말 부탁
드리겠습니다 안녕하세요 성수동에서
fmb 하고 있는 성수동 영보스
김종영 있니다네 반갑습니다 대표님
먼저 대표님 운영하고 계시는 매장에
대해서 좀 이야기를 나눠볼까 하는데요
저도 지난 주 일요일에 답사를
다녀왔어요 오후에 가서 밥을 먹고
구키 씨에 가서 쿠키를 포장한 다음에
오투 7에 가서 수플레를
맛보았습니다 웨이팅을 해서 들어갈만큼
사람이 정말 많았는데요 먼저 오후부터
이야기를 나눠보겠습니다 입니다 오후는
어떤 장인가요 오후는 지금은 일본식
가정식에 일본식 덮밥 전문점으로
바뀌였어요 한끼에 좀 든든한 그런
식사를 제공하는 덮밥 집입니다 어
맞아요 최근에 리뉴얼을 하신 걸로
알고 있는데 혹시 어떤 이유로
리뉴얼을 하게 되신 건지 저희가
18년도부터 오후라는 매장을 시작을
했었는데 그 당시에는 좀 밥집이 많이
없었어요 거의 상가가 없다 보니까
그래 저희가 그 당시에는 좀 여기
주변 분들에게 맛있는 밥을
제공해야겠다는 생각을 하고서 매장을
만들었는데요 그렇게 하고 거의 한
6년이 되다 보니까 이제 주변에 너무
맛있는 집들이 많이 생긴 거예요네
그래서 조금 더 재미있고 좀 더
인상깊고 좀 더 새로운 메뉴를 좀
제공하고 싶다는 생각이 들어서 저희가
이제 리뉴얼을 하게 되었어요 오
맞아요 저 메뉴 이름이 굉장히
인상적이었는데요 저도 규동이 먹으러
일본 가려다가 오후라는 매뉴를
먹었는데 제 옆 테이블 실제로 아이
가 있었어요데 아이가 메뉴판을 보더니
엄마한테 하는 말이 엄마 메뉴 이름이
너무 귀여워 였거든요 아마 다들 같은
반응이 것 같은데 메뉴 네이밍 과정이
좀 궁금한데 혹시 말씀해 주실 수
있나요 저희가 이름을 좀 고민을
하다가데 오후라는 이름으로 너무 오랜
시간 이제 매장을 했다 보니까
바꾸기는 어려워서 좀 어떤게 좀
재미있는 요소를 줄 수 있을까
손님들이 왔을 때 좀 더 새롭게
느끼게 하고 싶었어 가지고 이름도
약간 일어나니 오후 조금 늦게
늦장부려서 일어나니까 벌써 오후여서
밥 먹으러 가야 된다 좀 이런 뜻으로
지었어요 그러다 보니까 이름들도 좀
더 재미있고 손님들이 봤을 때
메뉴판을 보고 좀 이런 시간들이 메뉴
고르고 나면 좀 지루할 수 있잖아
메뉴 나오기까지 그때 좀 재미를
어떻게 주고 좀 어떤 경험을 좀
선보일 수 있을까 고민하다가 조금
재미있게 좀 메뉴를 좀 표현해 본
거예요 어 아 너무
재밌었습니다네 다음은 투 7 외장으로
넘어가겠습니다네습니다
오투 7은 어떤 매장인지 이름을 좀
어떻게 정하시기 되신 건지 설명을
같이 해 주시면 좋을 것 같아요네
아요 오투 7은 저희가 지금 수플레가
좀 부잉 전문점이에요 그래서 커피
에스프레소 머신이 없어요 다 기다려야
되는 메뉴들인데 저희가 이름을 짓게
된게 사실 영화에서 좀 영감을
받았어요 제가이 매장을 준비하면서
영화를 보다가 이제 그 5투 7이라는
프랑스 영화가 있어요 내 용상은 살짝
뭐 그 다른 얘기긴 한데 큰 의미는
그 시부터 7시에 그 자유로운
시간이라는 뜻을 가진 뜻인데 그때
제가이 매장을 창업할 때가 27
28이 되었다 보니까 친구들은 이제
다 직장 이제 신입이 가지고 너무
바쁜 거예요 그래서 아이 친구들이 좀
그 퇴근 시간에 조금 와서 좀
여유롭게 힐링을 하는 공간을 만들어
보고 싶다 좀 이런 생각이 들었어
가지고 직장인들도고 시간에 와서 좀
시간을 입고 여유와 힐링을 즐기는
공간을 만들자 하는 뜻 스스로 그래서
5투 7 5투 7이라고 지었고 그
저희가 슬로건이 타임투 be 프리 좀
자유로운 시간에 천천히 즐겼으면
좋겠어서 모든 메뉴들도 기다려야 돼요
어
맞아요네 또 인상 깊었던 점이 실내
조명이 거의 없고 좀 채광에 의존하는
그런 느낌이 좀 강 있어요 공간을
구성함에 있어서 의도하신 점이 있다면
좀 설명을 해 주시면은 방문하시는
분들이 좀 재미를 느끼실 수 있지
않을까 그 제가 의도한 부분은
아무래도 자유로운 시간이다 보니까 좀
시간 개념 을 좀 잊어 드리고
싶었어요 그러다 보니까 저희가 조명이
진짜 없어요 그래서 조명이 없고
광에만 의존을 하다 보니까 좀 채광을
좀 느끼지 좀 저녁이 돼도 좀 따뜻한
그 분위기의 그 조명이 있어서 시간의
개념을 좀 조명으로 많이게 해드리려고
갑자기 어두워지거나 아니면 또 갑자기
좀 밝아지면 좀 시간이 확 변화가
느껴지잖아요 저희는 애초에 어둡게
했기 때문에 좀 시간이 가는 줄
모르고 천천히 시간 좀 즐기셨으면는
바람에 의도를 해봤습니다 어 또 그런
숨겨진 뜻 수 있었네요 어 맞아요
실제로도 창이 되게 많이 있었어요네
아무래도 최강에 의존하다 보니 그랬던
거 같습니다 그러면 다음으로는 5투
7 아래에 있는 투데이즈 인어로
넘어가 볼게요 투데이즈 너프는 어떤
매장인가 투데이즈 너프는 에스프레스
바예요 그래서 정말 이제 커피에
집중한 커피 집이라고 보시면 됩니다
원래는 성수 빈티지라는 매장으로
운영하셨던 걸로 아는데 혹시 좀
전환을 하시게 된 계기가 있나요
저희가 전 하게 된 계기는 사실 성수
빈티지도 되게 이제 인기가 많은
공간이었어요네 팝업도 진짜 많이 하고
유명한 연예인분들도 막 생일도 하고
막 이랬는데 사실 운영적인 효율
부분이나 제가 이제 처음에 구상했을
때 좀 생각한 부분이랑 조금 차이가
나서 내가 잘하고 정말 좋아하는 걸
좀 더 집중을 하고 싶다는 생각이
들어서 저희가 로스팅 실을 이제
그쪽에 안에 넣으면서 로스팅도 저희가
직접하고 그다음에이 직접한 원두를
제일 맛있게 좀 제공할 수 있는
에스프레소를 좀 만들어 보자라고
해가지고 거기는 사실 개인적으로는
정말 커피에 정말 집중한 공간이에요
그래서 정말 다양한 원두를
에스프레소로 즐기시고 커피를 정말
좋아하시는 분들을 위한 공간이라고
보시면 될 거 같아요 맞 실제로
외국인 분들도 굉장히 많이었던 걸로네
지금도 외국인 손님들이 거의 한
40% 그렇죠 저도 되게 신기했던
그런 있습니다 서울숲 카페거리
초입에가 보시면은 오후 5투 7
투데이즈 너프가 이렇게 같이네
네대 그래서 조 의도를 하신건지
아니면 우연히 자리를 찾다보니 그렇게
된 건지가 좀 궁금한데요 의도는 한
건데요 이제 생각만큼 의도가 잘 실현
안 됐었어요 제가 처음에 오후 자리를
찾을 때 그 거리가 다 가정집이
그래서네 근생을 할 수 있는 공간이
거의 없어서 사무실을 쓰고 계신데
거기가 되게 비어 있는 사무실 같은
느낌이었는데 골목 느낌이 너무 좋아서
어네 제안을 드렸어요 저희가 권리금
드리면 혹시 나가실 생각이 있냐
그래서 저희가 거기 자리를 시작했고여
건물들이 나오기를 기다렸는데 다
가정집이다 보니까 근데 어느 날
보니까 이제 이사를 가기 시작하시는
거예요 그래서 바로 부동산에 물어봐서
어 건물주 바뀌셨다 바꾸실 계획이
있다 그래서 저희가 제안서를 써
가지고 어 저희 이런 매장을 이런
컨셉을 할 건데 저희한테 통임대 주실
생각이 있으시냐 이렇게 제안을 해
가지고 저희가 통임대 하게 된 거죠
그쪽 거리가 약간 일본 느낌도 나면서
아 의도를 하셨던 분이시라는 거
거죠네 그러면 다음은 구키 씨로
넘어가 보겠습니다 많이들 아실 것
같지만 그래도 구키 씨 한번 소개
부탁드릴게요 저희 우키 씨는
이름에서도 조금 힌트를 얻으실 수
있는데 쿠키를 약간 좀 언어 유의
버전으로 한 거예요 그래서 저희는
쿠키를 메인으로 한 디저트 이제
핸드메이드 프리미엄 디저트
전문점이에요 쿠키랑 스콘 그리고
케이크 이렇게 큰 카테고리 세 개
안에서 매일 30가지 이상의 디저트가
나오는 그런 디저트 전문매장입니다네
쿠키가 정말 맛있었습니다 대표님
감사합니다 쿠키이 처음 서울숲에
입점했을 때가 코로나 시기였던
걸로는데 그 당시에 서울 숲에 그
정도 면적을 제공하는 카페가 거의
없었던 걸로 제가 알고 있어요 어떻게
보면 되게 과감한 시도였다고 생각이
드는데 어떤 확신이 있으셔서 그렇게
진행을 하시게 된 건지 말씀해주실 수
있을까요 제가 그 장 자리를 본 거는
코로나가 터지기 전이었어요
공실이고 비어 있어서 어 저만한
규모가 그 거리에 없어서 아 내가
하나 하면 너무 좋겠다라는 생각을
있었는데 그래서 그 건물주 분한테
계속 저희가 제안을 보내고 있는
상황이었고 공시 근데 이미 6개월이
된 상황이었는데 그때 이제 코로나가
갑자기 터진 거예요 저희가 계약하기로
했는데 그래 가지고 사실 많이
말렸어요 이거 진짜 해도 되냐고 근데
저는 이때 아니면 이런 건도 안
나오고 또 그냥 그 건물이 주는
느낌이 너무 제가 하고 싶은
느낌이었어 가지고 과감하게 계약하고
오픈을 하게 된 거죠 어 너무
대단하신데요 그래서 이제 오픈하고 좀
많이
힘들었습니다 지금은 잘
됐으니까네 제가 가보니까 쿠키가
진열되어 있는 곳 옆으로 팝업 존이
약간 있더라고요 실제로도 다른
브랜드들 측에서 협업 제한이 많이
들어오는지네 저희가 이제 를 진짜
많이 하고 있고 또 제안을 많이 받고
있어요 근데 저희가 다은 못 하고 좀
할 수 있는 범위 안에서 저희가
최근에 했던 거는 이제 디즈니
주라기 공 주라기 월드가 공원인가 그
30주년 행사했을 때도 저희가
콜라보로 해서 저희가 디저트들 맞게
개발해서 같이 콜라보하고 전에도
지금도 계속 좀 제안 받아서 준비하고
있는 것들이 있어요 새로운 브랜드를
탄생시킨다는게 무에서 유를 창조해내는
느낌이자 네 저는 생해 머리가 좀
해지 좀 브랜드를 만드시거나 컨설팅을
하실 때 영감은 주로 어디서
받으시는지 여쭤봐도 될까요 영감은
진짜 일상에서 제일 많이 받는 거
같아요 그 모든 부분이 제가 먹고
마시는 걸 좋아해서이 어 그 fmb
업계에 들어온 것도 있고 제가 워낙
이런 걸 좋아하다 보니까 많이 다니고
여행도 많이 다니고 길 가다가도 정말
많이 얻고 생각날 때마다 좀 기록해
놓고 사진이나 이런 걸 많이 찍어
놓거나 좀 캡처를 많이 해 놓는
편이에요 그래서 좀 잘 맞고 좀
재미있어 하는 거 같아요네 어 저
너무
신기해서요 그러면 FM 사업을
하시면서 대표님께서 가장 중요하게
생각하시는 점이 있다면 무엇이
있을까요 저는 사람 사람 아 사람
중요하죠네 사람이라고 생각하고 있어요
저희 회사 이제 슬로건 자체가 배러
people 베럴 make 스라고
하는데 좋은 사람이 좋은 것들을
만든다라는 걸 해서 제일 fmb에서는
빼놓을 수 없는게 사람이라고 생각을
해서 아 사람을 제일 중요하게
생각하고 있습니다 맞아요 좋은 사람
곁에는 좋은 사람도 오는 법이니까요
다음은 성수동
[음악]
토박이신문 하나 사는게 나을 수도
있겠다라는 생각을 분명히 하셨을 것
같은데요 생각을 해보신 적이
있으실까요 많이 했죠 n
[음악]